AS WE JUMP TO OUR
NEXT GAME, MANSON FAMILY
VALUES.
MANSON FAMILY VALUES.
AT A RECENT SHOOT WITH
CONTROVERSIAL PHOTOGRAPHER
TERRI RICHARDSON, GHOSTFCE
CROONER MARYLIN MANSON RECEIVED
AN UNEXPECTED SURPRISE WHEN HIS
DAD SHOWED UP.
HERE IS THE PICTURE OF THAT.
THIS LOOKS LIKE IF THEY
RESHOT THE SHOW SALEM BUT
WITH CLOWNS.
I GUESS THE CRAZY APPLE
DOESN'T FALL FAR FROM THE
CRAZY TREE. THIS MAKES ME
WONDER WHAT ELSE THESE TWO
WOULD LIKE TO DO TOGETHER
LIKE I DON'T KNOW, GET DRUNK
AND MAKE TALKING DEAD
AWKWARD AS A TEAM.
SO COMEIDANS, I WOULD LIKE YOU
TO COME UP WITH AS MANY OF
THEIR FATHER SON ACTIVITIES
AS YOU CAN IN 60 SECONDS AND
BEGIN.
BRYAN CALL EN.
>> KILL A DRIFTER.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
ESTHER.
>> HAVING THE TALK ABOUT HOW
TO GIVE YOURSELF A BLOW JOB.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
NEAL BRENNAN.
>> NIPPLE CLAMPING.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
ESTHER.
>> LEARNING HOW TO MAKE
SUSHI WITH RAW HUMAN FLESH.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
BRYAN CALLEN.
>> TRAP THE NEIGHBOR'S CAT.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
BRENNAN.
>> HAVE THE TALK ABOUT THE
BIRDS AND THE BATS.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
ESTHER.
>> SHOOT A YOUTUBE MAKEUP
TUTORIAL.
>> CHRIS: YES, POINTS.
BRYAN CALLEN.
>> EAT THE NEIGHBOR'S CAT.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
NEAL BRENNAN.
>> UPSIDE DOWN CROSS SITS.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
NEAL.
>> BLOOD TASTINGS.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
ESTHER.
>> PLAY CATCH WITH A HUMAN
HEAD.
>> CHRIS: YES, POINTS.
NEAL.
>> WONDER WHERE IT ALL WENT
WRONG.
>> CHRIS: YES, NEAL.
>> DECLINE CALLS FROM DAVE
NAVARRO.
(LAUGHTER)